we've been saying for months that our
southern border is out of control that
it's completely open just in case you
think we've been overstating that
here's this more than 13 000 haitians
have now crossed into del rio texas
around bill malugen has been on this
story like nobody else he was there on
saturday here's part of what he saw
you're looking at right now is that is
the u.s side of the rio grande that is a
mass of several hundred
illegal immigrants who have just crossed
the rio grande and look at this several
hundred more streaming across as we
speak we're on a boat in the rio grande
this is the mexican side of the river
right now
you can see it's a never-ending stream
hundreds of people crossing the rio
grande
basically every hour and they're heading
over to the international bridge which
you can see in the background
look at that massive people
this is why the situation under the
bridge continues to deteriorate
this is insane the federal government
has to wake up
so a lot of questions here where these
haitians come from how they get here how
they afford it
but most pressing of all for americans
is where are these haitians going
u.s border patrol chief raul ortiz just
told malujian that of the 12 000
migrants under the bridge in del rio
only adult men will be deported here
right
the rest will be processed and released
into what you thought was your country
but turns out isn't
today fox news's peter ducey asked the
white house what our border czar thinks
about all of this
where's the vice president on any of
this isn't she supposed to be addressing
the root causes of migration
absolutely and she has been addressing
the root causes of migration by working
with countries in the region to ensure
they have the assistance they need to
reduce the number of people who are
coming and trying to make those journeys
across the border we've actually seen
some reductions in some of those numbers
that doesn't change the fact that this
is a very challenging
situation in del rio we're working to
implement our policies and we're working
to
ensure we are also addressing root
causes
so why does our guy have to wear the
obedience mask and that woman doesn't
so many questions somebody can answer a
lot of those questions is laura logan
host of the laura logan has no agenda
show on fox nation which is excellent
she joins us tonight laura thanks so
much for coming on so how do these
people get here where are they going
do you know
well you know what's interesting about
these people tucker is that based on
what they're telling border patrol
agents when they're interviewed
many of them in fact if not most of them
have come from chile and brazil and
countries like that they're not actually
coming from haiti because they've been
living in latin american countries ever
since the earthquake so that's years now
and what they are saying is that the
border is wide open everybody knows it's
wide open the message is loud and clear
they've seen people crossing there for
months the byte administration doesn't
do anything and this is their chance so
they said their lives are pretty good
i've seen many of them in the airports
here as they're cycled through and
distributed all over this country and
they're well dressed and you know very
lovely people from what i can tell you
know well-behaved great families but
what they don't look like is desperate
they don't look like for example
christians fleeing persecution from
nigeria who are actually in the midst of
a genocide who cannot even get asylum in
this country but who's the asylum laws
are actually written for them and what
you're seeing happen here is you know
those thousands of people and the bridge
tracker you know what the agents tell me
they've got like 24 porter johns for
those people several hundred of them
like around 300 escaped on sunday
morning they just ran away the
conditions are miserable they don't have
enough food they don't have any real
facilities or security it is an absolute
unmitigated disaster and what you're
seeing happen here is all those people
in the bite administration that came
from the open society foundation that
we're not allowed to talk about because
that'll be the end of us right they'll
come for all of us well you know what
those people those advisors they don't
want a border what does open society
mean it means no borders which means no
america right no countries that's why
patriotism and the flag and all of those
things are so evil today right they're
automatically white supremacy and
nationalism never mind that you can be
you know an african company a country
and be proud of your your flag and your
borders or you can come from kosovo or
wherever so what you're seeing is part
of a much bigger political picture it's
not just about the border and it's the
same strategy as afghanistan ignore
ignore ignore pretend it's not there and
not happening and the biggest thing here
tucker is that people keep using words
like failure they say oh they failed to
act no they chose not to act they chose
not to act because they have the outcome
that they want
that is such a good point and bless you
for making it laura logan thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else